so this report is apparently from Dave
Meltzer who's very trustworthy I will
have the exact numbers tomorrow but they
were terrible way below an aw all elite
wrestling pay-per-view possibly 10K for
TV orders I have the streaming tomorrow
it was nothing close to Canelo or Jake
versus Nate per Dave Meltzer Francis Ty
Fury only did 11,500 TV pay-per-view
Buys in the US and 56,000 on streams on
ESPN plus here's where it gets dicey and
chils alluded to this so many times
remember how they said Conor versus
Floyd biggest pay-per-view of all time
there's no way to prove it so it's kind
of like Netflix the numbers that we do
have to confirm it all signs would point
that this fight with Francis and Tyson
was lower than expected Francis has
never been a massive pay-per-view draw
he just wasn't Tyson Fury he also isn't
the biggest especially in America so you
have two guys who aren't not known for
being these massive stars in
pay-per-view so when I heard it's low
that makes sense